-This film has
an incredible cast.
-Yeah.
-You got to work with
an up and comer.
-Up and comer.
-In that scene. Yeah.
-Yeah. Yeah.
She's doing well for herself
-She's not bad, right?
-She's all right. Yeah, yeah
-Was she nervous
to work with you?
Do you think she was a little --
-I mean, she hid it well.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-She hid it well.
But no, it was --
I mean, she's Meryl.
-She's Meryl.
-She's Meryl!
-Do you feel it a little bit
when you do a scene with Meryl
-Yeah, I do.
-Yeah.
-I sort of --
I kept it together. I was like
"Okay, I'm keeping my cool
It's good." And she was
very good at just sort of
coming onto set and not
really having any airs
and graces or anything.
Like she's such --
It's amazing that she's, like,
such a legend
and we all love her so much,
but she is still sort of lik
this jobbing actor,
which is kind of amazing.
-Yes, it is.
-And so we were doing the scene,
and I was like,
"Okay, it's going well."
And we were having fun.
And it's obviously, you know
it's a funny, kind of harmless
scene and stuff.
And then at the end, when they
said that they were moving o
to another scene,
I just sort of went,
"Oh, we're moving on?"
And it was my only scene
with her, and I was like,
"It's over."
[ Laughter ]
My moment with Meryl is over
And I got really emotional
and just kept, like,
thanking her for letting me,
like, act and stuff.
[ Laughter ]
-It's also those moments,
you know, where you're talking
to somebody who's so legendary
that there's -- obviously
everyone has shared with the
how much they mean --
-Yeah.
-You're trying to find a new way
of saying something
they've heard.
-Yeah,
and so I just sort of -- I did
it, I feel like, with my body.
Where I just sort of held her.
-Yeah.
-Or tried to hold her.
-Right.
-And not let her go. I basically
forced her into a hug.
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And just said
"Thank you" again.
-And what do you think the odd
are that she went directly to HR
after that?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, because she's
a newcomer, I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-She might be too intimidated.
Sorry, Meryl.
-Congratulations on your Golde
Globe nomination.
-Thank you.
-That is wonderful.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I do want to --
I'm assuming -- I feel lik
last time you were here
was around this time of year
Are you going back to Irelan
for the holidays?
Are you going back
for Christmas?
-I'm going back to Ireland
for a bit and preparing myself
for the cold.
-Uh-huh.
-And I'm just going to sit
in my pajamas all day.
I mean I'm sure that's wha
I said to you last year.
It doesn't change.
-Yeah.
-I'm very boring.
-Yeah,
you haven't amped it up at all
-Not at all.
-If I recall, you're a little --
You don't love Christmas
shopping.
-No.
-I'm not great at it either.
Have you left it late?
Have you done it yet?
-No. I'm -- No.
I'm organized because
I had more time this year.
I basically haven't worked
in like six months.
So I've had a lot of time
on my hands.
[ Laughter ]
So, I went online early
and I got all my presents
a few months in advance.
-Oh, I'm very impressed by that.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, see I'm already worried
that I've left it too late
-You have, yeah.
-Yeah, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-You have, but it's the whole --
I don't know if you have
this when you go in to shops
but I just find like an hour in,
I'm like,
there's too many people,
it's loud, it's too bright
my back hurts --
-Yeah.
-I can't stand for this long
-So, you just go right to
a computer and you sort it out
that way?
-Yeah.
-Well that's good.
-It's the modern way.
-Yeah, it's very modern.